you can see the bike live on its side in
the road enrichment as the pensioner is
being treated by paramedics these
pictures were taken minutes after a
police outrider
escorting the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge was involved in a collision
with an 83 year old woman leaving her
with serious injuries they were all
driving really fast and it's a it's a
it's a residential area and I assumed it
was an accident
but I believe it was someone important
getting to an appointment in a statement
the Met Police said they'd referred the
instant the independent office for
police conduct adding the investigation
is in its very early stages and the
officer involved is assisting our
inquiries as a witness William and Kate
have been on their way to the annual
Garter ceremony in Windsor just one of
hundreds of engagements every year where
Royals are rushed through the streets to
get them to events on time maneuvers
that involve huge amounts of practice
and planning the only reason they have
this business s4 is because the event
itself is well publicized in the
national press so everybody would know
that William and Catherine are on the on
route from Kensington Palace to Windsor
Castle on a private event no it wouldn't
happen but you know throughout my
experience and years of doing that's and
also looking at ministerial protection
it has become an essential cog of
necessary to protect ministers and
members of our family it comes six
months after Prince Philip was involved
in a car accident in Norfolk in which
two women were injured in that case he
was criticised for not apologizing
quickly enough
the woman has been named locally as
Irene mayor and it's understood that
William and Kate have sent her flowers
in a statement the palace said the Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge were deeply
concerned and saddened hear about the
accidents on Monday afternoon their
Royal Highnesses have sent their very
best wishes to Irene and her family and
will stay in touch throughout every
stage of her recovery Irene is still
being treated in hospital as the police
and no doubt the royal household
continue to look into what went wrong
Rhiannon Mills Sky News